So if you read the headlines, it kind of seems
like the world is a terrible place, full of
violence, despair, and war. But it turns out
war is actually declining. We live in the
most peaceful time in human history. There's
lots of reasons why, but here are three of
the biggest ones. First, the spread of democracy
around the world. International relations
scholars have found consistently that democracies
don't fight wars with each other. Now why
is that true? There might be plenty of reasons
but one big one is that people who live in
democracies think it's wrong to start wars
with other democracies. They're legitimate
governments -- it's wrong to attack them.
But there's a flipside to this. Democracies
do often fight wars with autocracies. Luckily,
most of the world's countries are democracies now,
so the democratic peace is probably making
the world a much more peaceful place. Second
big reason why war is declining is nuclear
deterrence. Nuclear weapons, obviously big
and scary. However, nuclear deterrence may
have prevented a devastating war between the
United States and the Soviet Union. Everyone
recognized that they would lose. Statistical
evidence suggests that that is true -- that
most countries are too scared of the consequences
of nuclear war to fight one. There's a dark
side, and not just the risk of global annihilation
from an accident. If a country gets nuclear
weapons, they feel rather safer in being aggressive
in little ways, you know, small conflicts
or bullying around their non-nuclear neighbors.
This weird paradox, that nuclear weapons make
the world more violent and more peaceful at
the same time, is called the Stability-Instability
Paradox. The third reason that war has declined
has been the spread of the idea of national
sovereignty. This idea is hundreds of years
old, the idea that you shouldn't interfere
inside the borders of another state. But people
didn't take the idea too seriously, because
stealing new land used to be a major cause of
war. Think American European colonialism or
World War II. But after World War II, nations
pledged to stop. Since 1976 there hasn't been
a single successful war of conquest, except
for maybe Russia in Crimea, really recently.
Again though, sovereignty has a flip side.
Sometimes governments go to war against their
own people, and poor, weak governments often
collapse into civil war. Sovereignty makes
it hard for the international community to
intervene to stop either of those kinds of
wars. But on the whole, when you see those
terrible headlines, remember the world's way
better off than it ever has been. There's
less war and less violence than almost any
other time in human history.
That's something worth celebrating.